يبدو ان النجاحات الاخيره التي حققتها
مجموعه فاجنر ثارت حفيظه دول الغربيه التي
باتت مطالبه بمحاولته ايقافها الولايات
المتحده ستصنف منظمه اجراميه عابره للحدود
وستفرض عليها عقوبات الاسبوع المقبل وهذا
مؤكده البيت الابيض
لو كنا منظمه اجراميه دوليه فانتم
الزملاءنا لكن ثم امرا اخر اشار اليه
البيت الابيض
السؤال الان ما هي حقيقه التصريحات
الامريكيه حول هذا التوتر من الاقتراب من
عام على الحرب افلا نجم الكثير من من
تسيدوا المشهد في روسيا لكن ظل في الصوره
هاني بارزان يتصارعني على كسب والذفوتن
قائد باج مارع بروجين وقائد والعمليه
الجديد جراسيمون الخلاف الحالي بينهما
قصته تعود للسنوات والبدايه كانت في
فبراير
2013 قائد الاركان الجديد وقتها اغرس موف
يلقي محاضره عن اسس الحرب الهجينه نظريته
تعارض عقيده الجيش استوحاها من كتاب
الفيلسوف تولوي النظريه تقوم على مبدا
واحد على اربعه
اي عمليات عسكريه تمثل ربع الاستراتيجيه
ضد الخصم والبقيه هي تطوير الاسلحه
السيبرانيه تمويل المعارضه الضغط
الاقتصاديه على الدوله غير الصديقات كما
يسميها لكن بالتركيز على جزء العمليات
العسكريه فالنظريه تتضمن فكره انضمام
شركات خاصه للقتال مع الجيش هذه النظ
اوجدت فاجنر الا ان قرارا اخرج علىها تخرج
عن السيطره عن سيطره قاسموه تحديدا الاخير
اقر في 2014 اصلاحات هيكليه افقدت الجيش
نصف ضباطيه واكثر من 80% من ضباط الصف
الذين رفضوا تجديد عقودهم ذهب اغلبهم
للتقاعد ليس كلهم هنا كان بروكسجين في
الانتظار وقتها كان بروجين الرجل اعمال
بسجل اجراميه دون خبره عسكريه اسس فاجنر
في 2015 فاتحا الباب امام المنبوذين من
الجيش وحتى المساجين رواتب مغريه والحريه
مقابل السته اشهر من الخدمه
على الجحه
فاضيين اتهموه بخوض مغامرات فسببت بمقتل
مواطننا روس في سوريا عام 2018
الخلافه برزا الى السطح عندما فشل بروجيين
في الفوز بعقود حصريا لتموين الجيش منذ
2018 الجيش الروسي ايضا دفع البرلمان قبل
شهرين الى اصدار قانون ينظم عمل الشركات
الخاصه بالرجيم رفض الخطوه وتساءل عن
الهدف من اصلاح كيانا يعمل بكفاءه وان
بالقتل المتسلسليه
[موسيقى]